[Musique]
comment ça va regarder de quoi on parle
aujourd'hui on se parle aujourd'hui de
çà çà çà çà c'est ça ça en fait ce sont
les marshals motif à nc a une c'est
pourquoi elle c'est pour active noise
comme seul hic c'est à dire qu'on a des
écouteurs sont des trouilles en laisse à
réduction de bruit active avec un mode
transparent bref je vous présente
aujourd'hui les nouveaux écouteurs de
marshall et c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo
qui est réalisé en partenariat avec
marchal qui m'a dit un monsieur greuet
ce que tu voudrais pas présenter nos
motifs à une scène genre a dit bah vous
savez marshall j'aime beaucoup vos
produits donc oui bien évidemment laure
marchal connaissait on a déjà parlé de
marshall et on a continué tout de suite
avec ça
[Musique]
le truc que j'adore chez marshall met
vraiment que j'adore c'est ce look look
and feel leçon de légende l'ambiance des
concerts l'ambiance d'exemple guitare
moi j'ai vraiment livré affinités et je
vous le dis à chaque fois avec marche
alors ça c'est mon côté gratteuse yvon
côté gras de zicos j'ai encore mon ampli
marshall à la maison même si j'en fais
beaucoup moins et ça je le retrouve
toujours ici là j'adore ça c'est
vraiment hyper sympa j'ai l'impression
de toucher mon ampli chez moi pour
autant je ne suis pas avec l'ampli à
côté et lorsque je suis en déplacement
j'ai vraiment toujours ce petit côté là
ce look and feel concert ce look elle
field s'est pas boire rock'n'roll j'ai
l'impression d'aller l'écouter un vieux
concert dans une cave avec une odeur un
peu de cuir voyait truc un peu sympa et
c'est vraiment l'idée que je retrouve
ici avec ces à marshall motif a aidé
c'est alors au delà du côté son de
légende au delà du côté concerts dans
une cave je ne sais zulia vrai parti
pris au niveau de la marque et attendait
regarder ce truc là c'est quand même
complètement dingue c'est ça que j'aime
vraiment ici avec cette marque c'est que
j'ai l'impression de trouver ici un
bouton d'ampli ou sur une guitare que je
peux venir régler ça fait vraiment des
accessoires qui sont super super super
super super super jolie et l étui c'est
pareil voyez on est vraiment dans cet
esprit look and feel avec le logo
marshall le petit bouton ici pour venir
à perry très facilement vous venez de
recharger directement pas en dessous et
en plus de ça vous vient la recharger
sans fil dresse aussi un truc qui est
vachement sympa alors le p'tit pat de
rechargement sans fil n'est pas fournie
on est juste le petit cas pour venir le
brancher ça ira déjà très très bien
comme ça et voilà donc ça c'est vraiment
un truc que j'aime beaucoup c'est une
fois de plus escale signalé elle dira
c'est ce côté marshall ce côté look elle
fit regarder ça c'est l'écouteur gauche
s'écrit six élèves ils viennent se
positionner très facilement je prends au
plat jeu mais comme ça je tourne
légèrement et il trouve très très très
très très facilement leur place
dans les oreilles je prends hop jeux
tournois là et là comme ça je les ai aux
oreilles alors là j'ai la réduction de
bruit qui activaient expliqué je me
trompe pas du tout donc je vais la
désactiver via l'application mais ça je
vais vous montrer dans quelques instants
donc le truc est vraiment cool j'adore
alors après rassurez-vous parce qu'on
n'a pas tous les mêmes tailles
d'oreilles que vous avez des petits en
bout qui sont fournis à l'intérieur pour
venir s'adapter et bien à la taille de
votre oreille vous retrouver sa juste
ici la tac tac tac vous prenez vous
ouvrez vous avez trois tailles en fait
le small le médium de celui qui est
installé puis le lardin donc en fonction
de la taille de vos oreilles vous allez
retrouver sa et dernier point et je vous
l'indiquais tout à l'heure au point
savoir ce que vous retrouvez à
l'intérieur vous avez votre petit câble
qui est planqué juste là avec un petit
manuel à l'intérieur un petit guide de
démarrage qui est hyper simple et qui
fonctionne vachement bien alors le
premier truc c'est le confort je vous le
dis vous le prenez vous le posez et ils
ont une super tenu alors même si on est
sur un design rock'n'roll hallyday s'est
pas d'aller pogoter associés dans une
foule et dans ma vie de tous les côtés
mais si vous voulez faire du sport et
même courir avec pas regardé y'a pas de
souci ça tient la chandelle ans je suis
pas en train de courir mais ça tient
quand même vachement bien et alors après
c'est un truc qui marche mais
intéressant c'est qu'ils sont certifiés
ipx5 les écouteurs ça veut dire qu'ils
vont être certifié résistant à la sueur
à la transpiration dont vous pouvez
aller courir avec tuera absolument aucun
problème est double et est certifié ipx4
donc également résistant à la
transpiration s'il ya des petites
gouttes d'eau qui tombent dessus y aura
absolument aucun problème donc ça c'est
plutôt cool le confort et la les
produits sont sympa maintenant qu'en
dit-il de l'audio à c'est la grande
question et bien écoutez franchement ça
marche bien la qualité audio est au
rendez vous alors vous pouvez venir
paramétrer customiser un petit peu le
sont grâce à une application avec un
équaliseur et je vous le monde dans
quelques instants mais comme il est là
je trouve plutôt sympa ça marche plutôt
bien j'ai coûté plusieurs styles de
musique avec ce soit du rock'n'roll
autant bouliac sont en voie lorsqu'il
fallait les fréquences des grappes sa
tartine un peu j'ai mis du hip hop ça
fonctionne bien j'ai mis de la pop bref
vous pouvez écouter tous styles de
musique vous n'êtes pas obligés
d'écouter que du rock'n'roll sûr vous
pouvez mais vous n'êtes pas obligé donc
en terme de fréquence en termes de
qualité audio ça fait le boulot y'a pas
de souci là dessus à savoir qu'ici vous
avez des transducteurs dynamiques de 6
mm vous avez également deux micros pour
venir passer vos coups de fil il y en a
un qui est situé là et il ya 2 mais qui
est planqué juste ici sur le côté décès
d'optimiser le son lors de vos appels
téléphoniques et il ya un autre truc qui
à savoir et qui est vachement important
ici sa toute la partie autonomie alors
vous avez 4h30 d' écoute avec un
écouteur avec la réduction bruit active
et si vous la désactiver vous monte à 6
heures mais maintenant avec votre
boîtier de recharge vous montez en tout
et pour tout avec la réduction de bruit
active jusqu'à 20 heures de musique et
jusqu'à 26 heures sans réduction de
bruit active et vous avez également de
la charge rapide en 15 minutes de charge
notre parti pour une heure de musique il
nous faut trois heures en tout pour
revenir les recharger jusqu'à 100 % sont
les écouteurs qui fonctionne en
bluetooth 5.2 et je vous montre ce monde
applications déjà survenir reconnaître
ici retrouver mes écouteurs g le
pourcentage de batterie et ensuite tac
je peux y aller je rentre dedans
directement alors là ça c'est
intéressant parce que je vois déjà la
réduction de bruit était intense je peux
venir l'activé directement à une c'est
ça veut dire active noise comme souligne
réduction de bruit active donc là elle
est éteinte et là je suis en mode
transparence le mot transparence il fait
quoi et bien il vient prendre leçon au
travers des micros égale injecter
directement dedans pour pouvoir entendre
tout ce qui se passe autour de moi pour
vous connaissez probablement déjà un peu
l'histoire après vous avez un équaliseur
les connaisseurs il est plutôt sympa
alors le tout premier c'est ce qu'on
appellera leçon marshall d'origine c'est
flat ça bouge pas ensuite vous avez deux
modes le mode deux modes trois là vous
pouvez venir choisir entre un mode rock
mode spoken plus de la voix pop hip hop
électronique en fait vous avez des
bandes de fréquences qui vont changer à
chaque fois moi je me suis mis en son
rock je trouve ça pas mal et là je me
suis mis sur le troisième je me suis mis
en électro hop là qui me semble aussi
pas trop mal et puis après vous venez
également paramétrer vos contrôles
tactiles parce que oui vous vous en
douterez ici vous avez un petit pas de
tactile sur le petit n c'est en fait une
surface tactile que vous avez à droite
et à gauche hop là j'ai pu une fois je
lance la musique voilages appuyé deux
fois morceau suivant trois fois morceau
précédent et j'aurais pu et ça me refais
une pause et après j'ai les appuyons les
appuis long je peux venir complètement
les paramétrer ici c'est justement ici
ce qu'on n'a pas dans les commandes
tactiles alors regardez vous pouvez les
activer ou les désactiver je vous
conseille quand même donné les s'est
activée alors là j'ai une différente
entre l'oreille droite et l'oreille
gauche moi ce que j'aime et à l'oreille
droite c'est le contrôle du bruit c'est
à dire que je vais activé mal adduction
proactive je vais désactiver où je passe
sur le mode transparence j'ai la
possibilité de mettre mon des collisions
de changer mais mode déco l'isr mon
assistant vocal par défaut alors ne rien
faire du tout bon moi j'ai mon contrôle
du bruit et ensuite tout est ici je peux
venir les débloquer les blocs et si par
exemple je veux pas du mot de
transparence lépi sur l'oreille gauche
eh bien voyez j'ai mis mon assistant
vocal par défaut et si senna fun ça sera
syrie et ça marche très très bien j'ai
une charge est qu ici qui est éteinte
j'ai un son interaction version
d'interaction sais pas si vous
connaissez les écouteurs marshall c'est
le petit son de guitare que vous avez
lorsque vous changez de mode donc là ça
fait ch ou tout doux tout doux tout donc
le truc c'est sympa ça va cinq minutes
mais y'a un moment moi ça me sens un peu
par les oreilles donc ce que je fais si
ton son interaction et je désactive
comme ça je n'entends pas parce que je
pense que j'ai en train d'écouter de la
musique et que je switche entre mes
différents modes et que je l'entends il
ya un moment sympa il peut plus du tout
donc je le vire ensuite je vais avoir un
petit à propos ici voilà avec le modèle
numéro de série et compagnie je peux
venir il y aurait là pareil et c'est
tout c'est tout c'est simple c'est
efficace voyez j'ai l'essentiel que je
vais me retrouver ici dans mon
application réduction brute hâtive je
vais avoir mon équaliseur et le
paramétrage de la zone tactile ça ne
conviendra parfaitement bien donc les
écouteurs vous me direz ils sont sympas
hockey écoute a pris certains prix oui
mais oui bien évidemment ils sont vendus
vous en douterez et coûte 199 euros et à
199 euros vous avez une copie de
marshall avec des écouteurs retrouve
ailleurs laisse avec l'idée du son de
légende avec un design qui est très
iconique à qui est très particulier pour
moi ces écouteurs on vire les acheter
parce qu'on aime la marque parce qu'on
veut ce design marshall parce qu'on aime
l'esprit du rock'n'roll ou pas venir et
où j'en sais rien mais en tout cas
j'adore mois se désole je trouve très
différent par rapport à ce qu'on peut
retrouver et une fois de plus je trouve
que marshall hausse vraiment bien haut
niveau au niveau design au niveau créa
sous le doigt il ya un côté un peu un
peu matière un peu rubio qui est super
agréable le pavé tactile est allé on
pourrait quasiment pas le deviner pour
autant il est là il marche bien les
écouteurs en sont de bonne qualité ça
fonctionne bien la réduction de bruit
active elle est correcte et moi je les
aime bien les aime bien mais j'aime bien
l'esprit marshall je suis un peu biaisée
de toute façon là dessus parce que ça me
rappelle toute une partie de mon
histoire quand j'étais plus jeune et que
je faisais de la musique donc voilà vous
savez tout je vais tout raconter à vous
de me dire ce que vous empruntez comment
vous les trouvez vous c'est un marshal
motif à l'insee moi je trouve très très
cool ça fait un petit moment que les
avec moi que je les écoute que je
m'amuse avec qui je dois reconnaître que
j'aime bien le boulot café marshall la
suite vous avez compris le designer
voilà allez vous pouvez poser toutes vos
questions ou interrogations suggestions
juste en bas dans les commentaires
maintenant on se retrouve très vite pour
continuer à parler texte d'audio de
compagnie de plaintes ok ça c'est
vachement bien et merci à marshall
d'avoir autorisé cette vidéo a très bien
[Musique]